[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to swipe is what's in store for
you this week
Angela finds out how playing racing
games could make you the next Lewis
Hamilton I meet a creative team making
products and software that really jumps
out and gaffs all the tiny little
workers living inside us that's coming
up in our games review stay with us for
that and more after a quick look at some
of the techniques stories that made
headlines this week hey you call Madi
okay dialing now Google's updated
virtual assistant will be able to call a
restaurant hairdressers or other
business and hold a conversation on your
behalf to make a booking or check
opening times the company's been showing
off the software called duplex at its
Developers Conference and says it will
begin testing it this summer
uber has revealed its latest design
model for its upcoming electric flying
taxis the e CRM is 0:03 went on display
at the company's annual summit in
California aviation companies will
reportedly use the concept as a
framework while they developed flying
vehicles for uber the plan is to begin
test flights in 2020 and a group of
Afghan women and girls have created a
video game based on the country's fight
against the opium trade players have to
clear poppy fields and drugs and replace
the crops with saffron bulbs the young
women have actually made more than
twenty games since a nonprofit group
taught them to code and opened a center
three years ago but this game has drawn
media attention because of its message
now let's talk racing have you ever
dreamt of becoming a motor racing
champion angela has found a way in for
you and it begins with playing games
henrique true is not a gamer in the
traditional sense he's a full-time
surgeon but the skills he's developed
playing a racing game on his device a
couple of hours a night caught the
attention of McLaren to compete to
become one of his official simulator
drivers he's just one of the Millennial
gaming achievers setting the benchmark
for others to try and turn their hobby
into a career Darrin Cox is behind the
current campaign to find talent in the
virtual world via a driving game app to
see who can pull it off on a real track
we've taken guys from their computers
Gran Turismo in this case and
tournaments racing drivers over the over
eight years we found 23 guys that went
from Gran Turismo who became real racing
drivers in fact this morning one of the
guys a kid called Yan mardenborough was
racing in Japan again to Jenson Button
so this can happen we're now doing
something that we're different that was
Gran Turismo which is known as a
simulator but we're now taking people
from mobile phones from the Game Gear
Club and seeing if we can make those
skills transfer so from playing on your
mobile phone we're gonna give some of
the gamers experience of driving cars
like these mini LeMond cars this is
about experiencing the real by going
through the virtual route well with that
in mind I thought I'd give it a go - for
me there's a big divide leaping from the
virtual world to being physically
present was a completely different
experience but one that some are
mastering I have a bit of practice to do
both in the virtual and the real world I
think Mobile revenues account for more
than 50% of the global games market as
it reaches around 103 billion pounds
this year and the sporting worlds are
cashing in on the growing trend knowing
it attracts new followers but can the
motor industry really close the gap
between eSports and real racing what's
interesting here is that we've developed
to the point with mobile gaming that
there's enough simulation of those games
in a mobile platform to actually
demonstrate those qualities in something
much much smaller that you can pocket
it'll be interesting to see if the same
similarity exists with this mobile game
rather than a console based game and can
drivers demonstrate within this their
ability in the real world
also in the real world Motorsports is
expensive and as a result lots of talent
may never make it on the track but if
the virtual world can offer an
alternative way of becoming a
professional driver when the race is on
for those who never thought they get a
chance angela barn sky news
now a few weeks ago I showed you how
virtual reality was being used by brands
to influence the way we shop now it's
the turn of augmented reality after some
new research revealed how our brains
respond to a our experiences I've been
to visit a software studio which
specializes in bringing products to life
button on the right will take you
through to the filters the filters oh
the wonderful world of augmented reality
every item on these shelves is zapable
that means you can hold up your phone
and unlock layers of hidden
entertainment or information put there
by the zapper team this AR experience is
through the health benefits water so the
brand of water got in touch with you and
said we want to make our packaging say
lots of extra information absolutely
right the staff here can turn packaging
products and places into interactive
experiences what is the Lego shoe do it
does this AR is gradually working its
way into and onto our everyday items
it's no surprise really given that
Google and Apple launched their
augmented reality toolkits for
developers last year so get ready to see
a lot more of its which is obviously
good news for zapper we absolutely love
designing for this new creative canvas
one of the reasons is that and there's a
whole nother access to think about so if
you were just designing a 2d pack you're
confined by the limits of the pack that
with augmented reality you can use that
as your canvas and then bring things off
it coming out here here here and you're
designing between the object and the
phone and the space in between as you
look at these you can tap on different
parts of the brain the technology isn't
just a bit of fun researchers have
recently found that augmented reality
makes our brains work harder creating an
effect that companies will want to make
the most of if you're a brand
essentially what you want to do in any
sort of communication is to make some
some emotional impact and get into
memory so that it can affect people's
future behavior
and what we found out from the study we
ran is that augmented reality will
deliver that just the very experience
itself means the brains my emotionally
engaged and more is going into memories
zapper is about to launch an updated
model of its that box a mixed reality
headset kit to make zapping even more
immersive here's me playing the table oh
wow and it makes the noise soon they
call it an affordable version of
microsoft's hololens aimed at developers
who want to experiment with yet another
type of new media video games time now
and while we've been out here enjoying
the sunshine gaff has been busy working
out which games you should be playing
this weekend here he is with his review
of some of the latest releases
oh mama Connor is a little puzzle game
that turns your phone into a human body
everything's got its really nice classy
feel to it which everything in the 1920s
did I think and you basically have to
get body and a human through its daily
thing so you know there's like some bits
like you've got to stop germs from going
through someone's nose and these other
bits you just got to open his eye and
start the sort of film that gets you
going on your daily life and it is
really good but basically there's a
little puzzle for every single bit so
you work out one bit which maybe you
know helps you breathe then on the next
screen you've got to work out another
bit for a different body so if you're
like me and getting your head around
puzzles is quite hard for you then it
still looks really nice anyway so you
can just look at it it might shock you
to learn that a man with tattoos and a
silly beards is quite into craft beer
and what's better than drinking craft
beer making it I mean not really but
brew town is still really good it's a
little management sin that puts you in
control of a bunch of breweries and you
have to make really nice beer sell it
and that unlocks other bits in the game
it's a stunning looking game considering
this a mobile game and it plays really
slick as well you think it would chug
along but it doesn't at all one of the
best things though is you get to design
your own beer
labels and for some reason I've become
really into designing beer labels for a
beer I'll never get a drink
rage injustice is a nice little
throwback to those 90s fighters that
pretty much anybody who plays video
games over the age of 30 definitely
played so if you like stuff like Double
Dragon Streets of Rage you're gonna be
really into there it's a property little
arcade game which you can just pick up
jump in and it's fun because I mean it's
just running around the city beating up
things smashing things and shooting
things which that is just fun I've been
playing on the switch which is a perfect
thing for it because it's not the kind
of game you're gonna sink loads of hours
in front of the TV in front of but it is
the type of game that if you're on a
commute and you got a spear like 2025
minutes you're gonna have a really
really good time with it
well that's it for this week's show
don't forget to join us again for more
swype next week and in the meantime
follow us on twitter at sky news white
then you can see what we get up to
throughout the week have a great weekend
bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]